Prof: I'm going to begin
by going over briefly the
episodes that I didn't get to
cover in the last lecture
because we ran out of time.
Of course, I am not going to go
over every single episode in the
novel, otherwise,
we would be here for the whole
year, at least.
But I thought I'd say a few
things about the adventure of
the dead body.
We have moved from the
brightness of the road to the
darkness of the episode of the
dead body.
This is another instance where
appearances conspire to fool Don
Quixote,
although here it is,
as the text says,
seeing artificial,
that is, without artifice,
without--because he doesn't
turn to people with a corpse
into characters from the
chivalric romances;
this is what is unique about
this episode.
Reality, as it is,
is strange enough,
so he does not try to turn them
into characters from the
chivalric romances.
Don Quixote's reaction is still
to attack, as he did the monks
in the episode leading to the
fight with the Biscainer.
This is another episode with
some religious resonances and we
will have a few and we have had
some before.
The episode of the merchants of
Toledo, for instance,
is one that comes to mind.
It has religious resonances
because it is a funeral
procession and because one of
the men,
the one injured by Don Quixote,
claims to be an ecclesiastic.
After all is said and done,
it turns out he's not quite
ordained yet,
and so forth.
Sancho, again,
fears the police because now
Don Quixote has injured a person
of some note,
and Don Quixote may now be
excommunicated from the church
for having injured someone,
even who is going to become a
priest and who's not yet a
priest,
so he's now not only a fugitive
from justice,
but in some ways,
also, a fugitive from the
church.
Now, this is the episode,
also, where Sancho calls Don
Quixote the Caballero de la
Triste Figura,
which Jarvis translates as a
Knight of the Sorrowful Figure.
This is on page one
thirty-nine, which brings us
back to characters with physical
defects that I spoke about
before,
and certainly Don Quixote,
as we will see in the quote,
has some marks and physical
defects that make him stand out,
and lead to Sancho's calling
him that.
When asked by Don Quixote why
he called him such a name,
Sancho answers that:
"because I have been
viewing you by the light of the
torch that unfortunate man
carried;
and in truth,
your worship makes,
at present, very near the most
woeful figure I have ever seen;
which must be occasioned either
by the fatigue of this combat,
or by your want of teeth."
Because you remember that he
has lost several teeth,
having been struck by one of
the stones that the shepherds
hit him with.
So this is a part about his
physical defect,
his injuries,
and uniqueness as a physical
being.
But at issue is also Don
Quixote's awareness that his
adventures will be written,
or, in fact,
that they are being written.
And Sancho's invention of the
epithet has taken place as the
text is being composed,
the text that we read.
This is consonant with the
issue of the novel being a work
in progress, not a fixed text,
but one that is being made as
we read it.
This is a very significant
passage that I don't think has
been remarked on by criticism,
but it is page 139 to 140,
at the bottom of page 139,
when Sancho has just explained
that he looks the way he looks
for the reasons that I have just
given,
and then Don Quixote replies:
"'It is owing to neither,'
replied Don Quixote,
'but the sage,
who has the charge of writing
the history of my achievements,
has thought fit I should assume
a surname,
as all the knights of old were
wont to do: one called himself
'The Knight of the Burning
Sword';
another, that 'of the Unicorn';
this 'of the Damsels';
that 'of the Phoenix'..."
And so forth and so on.
So if you read carefully you
realize that Don Quixote assumes
that it is being written as they
go, which creates a kind of
impossibility.
How can it be written as they
act?
Are they following a script,
or is the writing following
what they do?
This is left unclear,
but it feeds into all of the
meditations that you find in the
novel about the nature of
literature, and the nature of
writing.
Now, in addition,
in this episode death becomes a
presence in the novel.
During the brawl at the inn Don
Quixote was taken for dead--
if you remember--which will
happen again in the novel,
Grisóstomo's dead body
presides over the episode about
his tragic love for Marcela;
so this episode highlights that
presence of death in the novel.
Death brings an element of
seriousness to these comical
episodes,
it lurks as a reminder of the
characters' vulnerability and
generally of the human need to
create art in the face of
certain extinction.
And here I want to bring in two
lines from a poem by Wallace
Stevens,
the great American poet,
about whom you will hear a
little more in today's lecture.
And the line is:
"Death,
mother of beauty within whose
bosom will devise our earthly
mothers,"
meaning death drives humans to
create beauty.
So this is why the presence of
death in the Quixote in a
general sense is so important.
Now, the adventure of the
fulling hammers--
we don't know what a fulling
hammer is,
we don't know what it is in
Spanish,
batanes,
they don't exist any more.
This was kind of a machinery to
spin wool or something that is
driven by hydraulic force,
by a river or a stream going
by, and it makes this awful
noise.
We continue in the darkness,
but there is strange noise that
frightens the protagonist,
although Don Quixote denies
that he's frightened adamantly.
But this episode has four
elements that I want to bring
out.
First is the story of
goatherdess Torralba--Remember,
she's the one...
This episode,
this cuento de nunca
acabar, this never-ending
story is told,
the story about the sheep being
brought across the river.
Sancho is telling the story,
and he tells Don Quixote,
please, do not interrupt me,
and keep track of the number of
sheep.
He says, All right.
So at one point he asks,
"how many sheep?",
and Don Quixote says,
"I can't remember,"
and that's the end of the
story, and Don Quixote is very
angry, why?
And he says,
well, because I told you those
were the conditions,
and so forth.
Now, this is a story that is
very funny,
it's also a love story,
if you look into it between
these two goatherds,
but it is also a story in which
the issue of language and
reality is underlined,
because here Sancho is
demanding a kind of literality.
I mean, literally:
one sheep, you say 'sheep' and
there is one sheep,
you say 'sheep',
there is another sheep.
You have to count every single
one, language cannot abstractly
say forty-five sheep,
it has to say one sheep,
two sheep, three sheep,
four sheep.
This is a very elementary way
of conceiving of language,
but this is what Cervantes is
bringing in that these folk
tales sometimes contain very
interesting elements about the
nature of story telling.
Now, this is--I don't know if
you know any such stories,
but I remember in my childhood
hearing some of them.
Now, the second part we have
already mentioned,
and it's the fact that Sancho
defecates out of fear,
of course.
Sancho goes to the bathroom out
of fear.
He tries to hide it from Don
Quixote, but Don Quixote smells
it and tells him to please move
away, that he can't stand the
smell.
Classics of literature--I think
I said this at the end of the
class after the lecture--
classics of literature contain
the whole range of human
experience,
including the most humble
physical functions,
and this is an instance of that.
There are similar episodes in
Chaucer,
I'm sure, as you remember,
and in Dante also,
in Inferno,
there are various scatological
episodes in Dante,
too, but none as humble as this
instance where Sancho cannot
contain himself and has to go to
the bathroom.
Another element is the fact
that Don Quixote beats Sancho
over the head,
in anger.
This continues to round off the
relationship between these two
characters.
It's a relationship that
includes tenderness,
it includes anger,
and that is very thoroughly
developed in the novel.
This is something new that,
in a way, Cervantes really
invented.
And finally,
what I would like to bring out
the question of how does Sancho
know that there is water in the
vicinity?
Remember, he says,
oh, there must be water around
here.
And how can he tell time by the
stars?
He knows what time it is by the
stars.
Well, here, we learn--you may
remember,
and I've always asked you to
read for details--
that Sancho says that he was a
shepherd once,
and hence he learned how to
find water for his animals and
fresh grass for them.
I think the significant thing
here is that we begin to learn
about Sancho's past
retrospectively.
It's not as if at the beginning
the narrator told us Sancho,
who was a shepherd,
this, and that,
and the other,
and then he begins the
adventures,
to begin to learn
retrospectively about Sancho's
activities in the past and how
he came to be who he is now.
This is a very effective device
to fill out the character,
and I want you to notice it
because there will be other
instances where we will find out
other things about Sancho's
past.
So his life is filled in on the
go,
not following a conventional
chronological progression,
this is what I want you to take
notice of as a narrative
technique.
Those are the episodes that I
didn't get to in the last class.
And now, we get to the second
part of today's class,
which has to do with these
three topics.
Now, why does Cervantes,
and why does the Quixote
focus so much on low class types
and even criminals?
This is something I've talked
about before,
but I will be harping upon
again today.
Now, we have spoken about
Maritornes,
who is a prostitute,
but there are others,
like for instance,
the servant who beats up Don
Quixote in the episode about the
merchants of Toledo,
the rowdies,
who toss Sancho in the blanket,
Andrés,
who's being beaten by his
master but who seems to be a
pícaro himself,
the first innkeeper,
who was, I've called him,
a retired pícaro,
and the prostitutes at the
first inn.
We will meet others,
quite a few other such types.
As we talk about the galley
slaves episode today we will be
attempting to answer this
question,
why the focus on these kinds of
characters,
about the abundance of low
class types and outlaws?
By the way, galley slaves--I
say this because I'm sure that
you have never heard of this
before,
it's not something that we are
familiar with--
galeotes in Spanish,
were prisoners or legally
slaves who were forced to row in
the galleys,
be they private or more often
owned by the crown.
That is, the ships move with
sails,
but also with ores,
and the ores were manned by the
galley slaves,
who sat in rows inside,
and were whipped to row harder
and harder.
It's a terrible kind of
punishment,
and I can go in detail about
the lengths of the sentences
there,
and the fact that most of them
didn't come back alive,
and so forth,
but that's what a galley slave
is.
The closest I think we have is
those chain gangs that we see
occasionally in some states of
prisoners going around in their
striped uniforms and so forth.
Now, let me anticipate some
ideas and redirect others that I
have already mentioned before to
give a context to what I'm going
to be saying.
The Renaissance is interested
in the nature of humankind
relatively independent of God.
Renaissance thinkers and
artists focus on characters like
the wild men,
for instance,
who are close to nature and
does reveal their belonging to
the natural world,
rather than to the social world.
The wild man is an individual
lost in the woods or in some
cave, who lives in a state of
nature, away from civilization.
In Spanish literature,
the best-known example is
Segismundo,
the protagonist of Life is a
Dream,
a play by Pedro Calderón
de la Barca that I will be
mentioning often during the
semester--
You may have heard of him
before.
These Renaissance thinkers and
artists also concentrate on
individuals who willfully become
marginal to society,
like madmen and criminals.
The underlying idea is that
society masks,
erases, or attenuates
fundamental traits of the human.
There is also an aesthetic
reason, social individuals are
types;
individuals in society become
types.
Their features are determined
by social conventions attached
to their station or trade,
whereas marginal figures are
individual in their appearance
and behavior.
Don Quixote and Sancho will
meet characters like Diego de
Miranda,
the man in green in Part II,
who lead boring lives because
they conform to social norms.
He is a rich hidalgo who lives
a life of ease in his estate,
and who lodges the knight and
his squire for several days in
his very comfortable house,
until Don Quixote gets bored.
Don Quixote and the
pícaros he meets,
on the other hand,
are not boring,
they lead lives of adventure.
They are appealing because of
their deviations,
just as they're physically
attractive because of the
deformities that they bear as we
saw in the last class.
Of course, epic heroes and
protagonists of chivalric
romances led very interesting
lives, needless to say,
full of adventures.
But those adventures took place
in a distant and vague past and
in abstract countries,
with generic qualities drawn
from literary conventions,
whereas the pícaros and
Don Quixote live in the present,
and live in a society that the
reader recognizes as his own.
The clash between the two is at
the core of Don Quixote,
of course, but the point is
that except in his imagination
Don Quixote never inhabits a
world other than that of Spain
in the late sixteenth century
among people involved in
ordinary activities who do not
violate the laws of nature.
No one flies,
for instance,
in the Quixote,
or performs feats that are
beyond human strength,
as happens in the epic,
or as happens in the romances
of chivalry.
We are about to come into an
episode where this clash between
idealized time and space meet
real time present day Castile.
I refer to the episode about
Mambrino's helmet in chapter
XXI,
and here is where your handout
may be of some use,
because in the visual part of
the handout I have there a
barber's basin.
I have the depiction of a
barber's basin because no one in
this room has ever seen a
barber's basin,
even myself,
because they are no longer in
use.
A barber's basin is this device
that the barber would use,
and it has an indentation like
that to put it under the
person's chin,
and for the neck,
and then to wash the beard and
the water to fall in it,
and so I wanted you to have it,
a depiction of that,
so that you will know what we
are talking about here.
Why Sancho says what a huge
head this giant had,
because of course,
it's a big basin like that.
So there are two important
elements in the Mambrino helmet
episode which is one of the most
famous and discussed in the
Quixote because it brings to
the fore the discussions about
the nature of the real that
dominates the discussion among
the characters,
but particularly,
between Don Quixote and Sancho,
as they do here.
The first element that I want
to bring out in this episode has
to do with the oath Don Quixote
made earlier in chapter X,
which by fulfilling it,
would close a loop in the plot.
Upon seeing the barber's basin
shinning,
he remembers the oath that he
made when he discovered that
part of his own helmet had been
damaged in the fight with the
Biscainer.
So he says that the opportunity
now,
when he sees the basin,
arises to fulfill the oath,
quote: "about which I
swore the oath."
As you know,
he tells Sancho on page 153,
when he sees the basin,
he says, this is the
opportunity to fulfill that oath
that I made.
Don Quixote had sworn the
following after the fight with
the Biscainer.
I quote: "I swear by the
Creator of all things,
and by all that is contained in
the four holy evangelists,
to lead the life of the great
Marquis of Mantua,
when he vowed to revenge the
death of his nephew Valdovinos,
which was not to eat bread on a
tablecloth,
nor solace himself with his
wife, and other things which,
though I do not now remember,
allow here for expressed,
until I am fully revenged on
him who hath done me this
outrage."
Unquote.
Of course, the outrage is the
damage to the helmet that he can
now restore with a new one that
approaches and that he plans to
appropriate.
The novel begins to acquire,
this is the point,
an inner density and substance
by means of these links,
these connections within the
plot, one linked to the other,
the oath and the fulfillment of
the oath.
Now, the second element that I
want to bring up has to do,
of course, with the confusion
created by the wet shining basin
that looks like a helmet.
Mambrino's helmet belongs to
the traditional Roland and his
various incarnations as Orlando,
Roland, Roland,
Orlando, who becomes Orlando--
This the Carolingian cycle of
chivalry that I mentioned in one
of my early lectures.
Mambrino's helmet is one with
Rolandian literature in Boiardo,
Matteo Boiardo,
a poem called "Orlando
innamorato,"
Orlando in love,
Reinaldo de Montalbán
kills the Moorish king Mambrino,
and wins his enchanted helmet.
In Ariosto Orlando
furioso--whom I have
mentioned before and will
mention several times in the
course of the semester--
the enchanted helmet had been
won from the Moorish king
Mambrino by Dardaniel de
Almonte--
not Sacripante,
as Don Quixote misremembers--
and Reinaldo de
Montalbán wins it when he
kills Dardaniel.
So this is the background of
Mambrino's helmet.
In his imagination,
Don Quixote acts like the
Carolingian hero in obtaining
the helmet from the Moorish
king.
So Mambrino's helmet has an
incontestable chivalric
pedigree,
a deep pedigree,
which makes it all of the more
ridiculous that it be confused
with a barber's basin.
So you have to have this
background to realize the
distance between this Mambrino's
helmet and the barber's basin.
This is why I wanted to give
you that background.
But there are attenuating
circumstances where Don
Quixote's error reality
contingency--
when I say contingency I mean
accidents--
conspire to confuse him,
as in the case of the dead
body.
The basin is not being used for
what it's intended,
for what it was intended to do.
The barber has it on his head
to protect his new hat from the
rain--
remember the detail,
he has a new hat and he puts it
on to protect it from the rain.
This is the only time,
by the way,
in which it rains in the entire
Quixote,
if you want to know a detail,
the only time when it rains in
the entire--
it doesn't rain very often in
Castile, by the way.
Castile is very dry,
and so this is consistent with
the real conditions of the
region--So it rains,
and it's being used to protect
the hat.
So the barber has it on his
head, I said,
to protect his new hat.
The poor barber is the victim
of this mutation,
of this circumstance.
It happens with other things in
the Quixote.
As you know,
the inn was originally a
stable, or parts of the inn were
originally a stable.
In the real world,
things are adapted ad
hoc for purposes other than
those they were made for,
there essence does not
guarantee their usage,
they are in flux.
Remember, what Don Quixote said
after the episode of the
windmills about mutations,
how things are in a constant
state of mutations.
So reality is in a state of
flux as is Don Quixote himself.
Hence, he takes the shining
barber's basin for Mambrino's
helmet.
This episode exemplifies the
modern radical doubt about the
power of the senses to grasp
reality,
which will become a topic of
the Baroque,
the period immediately,
or almost immediately,
after the Renaissance,
and about which I'll be talking
a lot later on.
Remember what I said about the
critical cliché,
that the first part of the
Quixote is Renaissance,
the second part is Baroque.
But the topic of our senses not
being able to really discern
reality is one that is still
with us.
It is a sort of doubt about the
real that we find even today in
a modern poem such as Wallace
Stevens "Man Carrying a
Thing," which is the poem
that you have on the other side
of your handout today.
I bring up this poem because in
one or two occasions the basin
is referred to as 'a thing',
"a thing that
shines,"
Sancho says,
as of yet lacking ontological
and phenomenological
specificity--
the ontological is being,
it's not specific,
it's appearance,
it's phenomenology,
is not specific.
And so it's called a thing.
And so I always,
when I come to this episode,
think of this poem by Wallace
Stevens,
Wallace Stevens being one of my
favorite,
if not my favorite, poet.
He was an American poet,
1879-1955, who spent almost all
of his life as an executive for
an insurance company in
Hartford, Connecticut.
Nevertheless,
he was really one of the major
American poets.
So: "Man Carrying a
Thing"
The poem must resist the
intelligence
Almost successfully.
Illustration:
A brune figure in winter
evening resists
Identity.
The thing he carries resists
The most necessitous sense.
Accept them, then,
As secondary parts (parts not
quite perceived
Of the obvious whole,
uncertain particles
Of the certain solid,
the primary free from doubt,
Things floating like the first
hundred flakes of snow
Out of a storm we must endure
all night,
Out of a storm of secondary
things),
A horror of thoughts that
suddenly are real.
We must endure our thoughts all
night, until
The bright obvious stands
motionless in cold."
I don't think the bright
obvious ever stands motionless
in cold in the Quixote,
but I think that this poem
brings--dramatizes,
what is happening in this
episode with this thing,
that Don Quixote takes to be a
helmet,
and Sancho knows is a barber's
basin.
This is a Cartesian problem,
since it was Descartes who
first gave full attention to it:
how do we really know the real?
Doubt, as the principle of
modern philosophy,
is present here,
already.
In this sense Cervantes takes
leave from Renaissance thought
and poetics as in many others
and moves towards the Baroque.
The basin will reappear and
provoke a full-fledged
discussion,
in the inn, among various
characters about whether it is a
basin or a helmet,
with the basin there.
It's a hilarious parody of a
scholastic debate.
The basin is one of those
things that the novel focuses
on,
and that I told you to take
notice of in connection with
Alberti's theories about
perspective,
because the basin is seen in
the distance,
in the depths,
and this is why it is difficult
to ascertain what it is.
Now, the second part of the
chapter contains what I called
Don Quixote's own chivalric
romance.
I don't know if you remember
this part, but you should.
Here we see Don Quixote in the
act of creating a chivalric
romance.
Remember, Sancho's asks him if
they shouldn't go and try to
gain some notoriety and fame by
doing important things,
and so then Don Quixote
launches on this narrative about
a chivalric romance,
which he creates out of
elements drawn from many of
these romances.
He has been able to condense
from various romances the
essence of the chivalric
romance, the basic story.
This story reveals what he has
in his head.
This probe into the mind of a
character is also new in
fiction.
Here and elsewhere,
as in the case of Cardenio,
whom you're going to meet right
away,
we get intimations of a
character's subconscious,
not just of his actions,
as was the case in the epic,
the romances of chivalry,
and even in the picaresque.
Here we get something about Don
Quixote's--this will happen
several times in the novel.
The story of this chivalric
romance is an exercise in
narrative, but which Cervantes
is underlying in the conventions
of the chivalric genre;
the fact that there is a kind
of basic blueprint or structure
upon which anyone can embroider.
This is true,
by the way, of popular forms of
narrative,
like James Bond movies,
of which they keep making more,
and more, and more,
because the basic blueprint is
there,
and then all you have to do is
to make a slight change in one
character here,
or a slight change in this kind
of adventure,
and you have a James Bond.
The same was true with Conan
Doyle,
and Sherlock Holmes stories
and, of course,
as I've mentioned several
times, with soap operas,
which is always--Latin American
soap operas is always that the
poor secretary has an affair
with the son of the very rich
boss,
and you go from there,
and she has a baby,
or she doesn't have a baby,
and you know.
So Cervantes,
as with the picaresque--
and we're going to discuss it
in the following discussion of
the galley slaves episode--
Cervantes is concerned that the
conventions of literature,
its topics, draw it away from
real life.
That even the new genres,
new in relation to the
classics,
reassert their literariness by
deploying these conventions,
which turn into predictable
systems.
Awareness of this possibility
is crucial to the whole Quixote
and to Cervantes's entire work;
how convention obscures the
real and shields us from it;
how literature quickly retreats
to formulas, like those in Don
Quixote's mind.
Self reflexivity helps to point
out these conventions and to
show their disconnection from
reality;
they are being self generated
and self contained--
I am reminded here,
I don't know if you've seen
The Kiss of the Spider
Woman,
but it's a great movie,
and you remember that Molina is
telling his cell mate all of
these movies that he has in his
head,
that he has memorized,
and there are people who have
memorized the plots of many
movies and can condense them
into kind of a generic movie,
the way Don Quixote is creating
here a kind of generic chivalric
romance.
This also plays into the game
of mirrors that the
Quixote is becoming,
it is a story within the story,
and the large story is a parody
of a romance of chivalry.
It is, this,
what is called in French
'composition en
abîme,' and in English
it's 'the infinitely receding
sequences',
that we found in
Velázquez,
Las Meninas,
the story within the story,
like the painting within the
painting,
like the play within the play,
in Hamlet.
I first visualized this as a
child looking at the label on a
condensed milk can,
and the label depicted a
condensed milk can with the same
label,
within which there was another
label with the same condensed
milk can,
and so forth and so on,
and I had the vertigo of not
knowing whether I was part of a
larger condensed milk can or
some such depiction.
Guys, they don't go to
barbershops any more,
I don't think,
it doesn't look like it to me,
but some of you do,
but little boys discovered this
in barbershops.
When you sat in the barber's
chair and you were surrounded by
mirrors,
and suddenly you see yourself,
wow!,
you get lost in an infinity of
reflections of yourself.
That is an infinitely receding
sequence.
That is there is no without,
if you are within that,
there is no without,
you're always--
Everything is within
literature, hence,
there is no authority that
orders the universe of fiction,
which is continuous with that
of reality.
The only infinite being would
be God,
so to posit this kind of abyss
like universe is a form of
radical skepticism on the part
of Cervantes,
and of Shakespeare, by the way.
Here the authority within that
fiction, this house of
mirrors--I'm sure you've also
gone to the house of mirrors--is
a madman.
Don Quixote as within the
picaresque--and we will get to
that--it will be Ginés de
Pasamonte.
Another important point about
this generic chivalric romance
that Don Quixote comes up with
here,
in answer to Sancho's question,
is that Don Quixote reveals his
worries about his lineage.
He has to acquire fame to
aspire to marry a princess.
Behind this apparently
naïve preoccupation lays
one of the social issues at
stake in the novel,
the question of social class
and privilege,
and the possibility of
acquiring it,
rather than inheriting it.
You remember that he speaks
here about...
He will acquire enough fame by
dint of his own valor to merit
being married to a princess.
Even in the relationship within
the knight and his squire,
there are intimations of a
leveling of social classes here,
in this.
And you will see,
as we move to Part II,
that this will increase as
Sancho's importance in the novel
increases.
So this is one of the topics,
but here we get another glimpse
at Don Quixote's subconscious.
He is worried about his lack of
nobility, his lack of
aristocratic background.
Now, we get to the galley
slaves, which is,
again, another famous episode
in the Quixote.
This is chapter XXII,
Part I, because it also shows
Cervantes dealing with the
question of literature,
more specifically the
picaresque.
Notice, by the way,
in this chapter,
the mistranslation when Jarvis
renders 'alcahuete' as
'pimp,' on page 166,
when it should be 'go-between,'
the galley slave who has been a
go-between--
remember?--that Don Quixote
actually praises,
and in the original it says
alcahuete.
Alcahuete is someone who
arranges marriages and illicit
encounters between lovers and
all of that, but is not a pimp.
A pimp is an agent for
prostitutes.
Alcahuetes or
go-betweens have been praised
throughout the ages,
even by Saint Augustine,
at some point;
he praises the job that they do
in arranging couples to meet and
become lovers,
just a detail about the
translation.
I don't want to belabor the
failings of the translation,
which is a pretty good one.
Now, again, why the picaresque?
You might be getting tired of
my talking about the picaresque,
but the picaresque is the new
fiction that precedes the
Quixote,
precedes Cervantes' work within
which, and against which,
he writes.
The picaresque comes up again,
not only because like the
pícaro,
Ginés de Pasamonte,
who is the main character here,
is a criminal,
but more importantly because
Ginés de Pasamonte is an
author.
When asked if his book is good
by Don Quixote,
Ginés replies--I'm on
page 169: "'So good,'
answered Ginés,
'that woe be to Lazarillo de
Tormes,
and to all that have written or
shall write in that way.'"
And when asked for the title
and if it is finished,
Ginés answers,
quote: 'It's called The Life
of Ginés de
Pasamonte,' replied
Ginés himself.
'And is it finished?' quoth Don
Quixote.
'How can it be finished?'
answered he, 'since my life is
not yet finished?
what is written,
is from my cradle to the moment
of my being this sent this last
time to the galleys.'"
Picaresque novels tended to be
called "Vida
de...,"
life of...
Vida de Lazarillo de
Tormes, Vida de
Guzmán de Alfarache.
So The Life of Ginés
de Pasamonte is obviously a
picaresque kind novel that he
has written about himself.
So Cervantes is talking from
here at the conventions of
autobiographical writing,
meaning, "how can you
write an autobiography if your
life is not over?",
is what Ginés answers,
and Cervantes is poking fun at
that,
so, which leads,
in autobiographical writing--
as in the Confessions of
Saint Augustine and so forth--
to the creation of a death and
resurrection kind of scheme.
That is, I am speaking about
the man that I formerly was
until I had a conversion,
by which the old man died and
the new one arose,
and so forth.
So this is what is behind this
little repartee here,
between Ginés de
Pasamonte and Don Quixote,
which is a satire of
autobiographical writing and of
the picaresque novel
specifically.
Here Ginés underscores
the fact that there is no way to
put a stop to it,
by saying that to the last time
he went to the galleys,
so every time he went to the
galleys he takes up the book
again and writes it,
and writes it,
and he says at one point here
that he doesn't mind going to
the galleys because there he'll
be able to finish his book,
so there is a kind of literal
continuity between life and
writing,
that is what is being made fun
of in this episode.
Now, you remember the whole
background of the picaresque,
because I've given it to you
many times,
from the Celestina to
Guzmán de
Alfarache,
1599, right?
At the time Cervantes was
writing Don Quixote,
and in the Guzmán de
Alfarache the protagonist is
a galley slave at one point,
so the allusion to the
Guzmán de
Alfarache is very clear.
Now, Ginés de Pasamonte
is one of the most important
secondary characters in the
Quixote --
This is not an oxymoron,
of secondary and important.
There are important secondary
characters,
and secondary characters that
are not important--
not only because it's really
fun and funny--
he's really a lot of fun,
and he will reappear--
but because he's one of the
storytellers in the book,
hence it's part of the book's
take on literature and the
nature of narrative.
Ginés is one of the many
storytellers in the
Quixote.
By this I mean characters who
not only tell a story or recite
a poem, but who are writing or
have written a book.
The most memorable of these
are, of course,
the narrator of the
Quixote,
who claims not to be the
author, the apocryphal Cide
Hamete Benengeli,
the translator, and so forth;
these are all characters who
have written a book.
There will be others;
Cardenio has written a book.
Cervantes is considering with
them the possibility of new
genres,
new forms of literature
emerging--which they are,
at the time that he is
writing--and showing the
mechanisms by which a new genre
is born,
a new genre,
meaning a new kind of
literature that is not merely
derived or copied from the
classics,
as was done or attempted to be
done in the Renaissance.
These are authors,
like Lope de Vega,
whose name I've mentioned many
times,
and I'm not going to put it on
the board because you must
remember,
who created,
as it were, the Spanish
theater,
national theater,
the comedia.
And so, Ginés is as
complex a figure as other
narrators of the Quixote
like Cide Hamete Benengeli,
and I remind you again,
and I'll do it probably again
in this lecture,
that at this point between the
sixteenth and the seventeenth
centuries,
the first professional authors
are emerging,
that is, authors who are trying
to make a living from their
writing.
Lope did, very,
very well, because,
of course, he wrote so many
plays and he did so well,
while Cervantes didn't do so
well, as we know.
Now, this interest in the
nature of literature and the
figure of the author in the
Quixote is because the
novel,
this novel, the Quixote,
is not so much about the
question of the book as it is
about that of the books,
in the plural,
as we saw in the episode of the
scrutiny of the library.
It is about the proliferation
of books made possible by the
development of the printing
press and the economic factors
that encourage editorial
production in the sixteenth
century.
The Quixote is the first
major work to consider how the
dissemination of books unsettles
received notions about the book
and about authorship.
These are, remember,
again, turn of the century,
sixteenth to the seventeenth,
new genres,
new authors,
like Mateo Alemán and
Lope de Vega,
who are professionals,
and so forth;
this is tied to the whole issue
of the books.
Now, I'm going to go into a
part of the lecture here that
might get a little dense,
because it's about this
proliferation of books in
relation to the author and the
veracity of the books.
I'll go very slowly,
because I, myself,
feel that it is a bit dense,
and I don't want to confuse
you, and if I do,
you raise your hand in protest.
The proliferation of books is
accompanied by a decline in the
social class of authors and of
the author figures,
by which I mean characters like
Ginés de Pasamonte,
who represent authors within
the fiction--
Now, take stock of this.
Ginés de Pasamonte is a
criminal, is a prisoner,
he's a galley slave,
however, he has written a book.
This is novel,
I mean, that someone of his
social class,
couldn't be lower,
is writing a book.
So, just as the production of
many copies of a single book
brings down the fetish value of
each single copy--
as happens with everything,
if you have too many of
something the value declines,
if you have very few the value
increases.
I have a two-dollar bill in my
wallet somebody gave me,
and I've kept it because they
say it is good luck,
but also because there are few
of those,
so this is the fetish value of
things that are few;
this we've learned in economic
classes since we were going to
high school.
But the opposite is true of the
authors and author figures
relevance, which increases as
the value of each copy of his
book decreases.
The authors now become the
guarantee of the work's worth,
as well as the one accountable
for it before the law.
In the case of the
comedia,
the Spanish plays,
where proliferation was rampant
to be 'de Lope,' by Lope,
became a sign of
excellence--like a trademark--
applicable as an indication of
value to things other than
plays.
You could say,
this thing is de Lope,
and it meant that it was very
good.
In the picaresque,
author and protagonists are
conflated into one,
book and author become one as
in the case of Ginés,
whose reductio ad
absurdum of this textual
strategy has been noted many
times--
the one that we've just seen.
A rudimentary equation could
perhaps be worked out.
These new authors break with
the strictures of renaissance
mimesis--
the idea of imitating the
classics--
in the sense then they innovate
leaving behind classical forms
and themes,
or subjecting them to
substantial transformations.
They are no longer like the
classics;
they are subjecting them to
transformations.
Hence, the dissent in social
status of the author appears to
be accompanied by an increase in
inventiveness and a rise in the
importance of the author--
is that clear?
It should be clear, no?
The higher the social class,
the less the invention,
because they follow mimesis;
they imitate the classics.
The lower the author's social
class,
the greater the invention,
hence more value attached to
the author,
which leads to the following:
the more invention,
the more value given to the
author--
Ginés de Pasamonte who
prides himself of having written
this book about himself.
This explains why,
as Alemán did before
with his Guzmán de
Alfarache,
Cervantes rushes to write his
second part,
once he learns that Avellaneda
has written a second part of
the Quixote.
He feels that the
Quixote is his invention,
his in every sense,
including the monetary sense;
that he's going to lose
revenues if somebody else writes
a Quixote.
So it seems that the impact of
these socioeconomic developments
on books and authors is
undeniable.
But there is another important
factor at work that issues from
the content of the book
themselves and its relation to
knowledge--
I hope that you have made that
clear.
This is clear;
and Ginés de Pasamonte
exemplifies the lowering of
social class.
Cervantes, himself,
was a very petty nobleman,
poor, and so forth;
so Ginés de Pasamonte is
important because he exemplifies
that drop in social class of the
author--
Now, Anthony Grafton opens the
introduction to his magnificent
New Worlds,
Ancient Texts:
the Power of Tradition and the
Shock of Discovery with
these words--
Grafton is a professor at
Princeton University--
the book is called New
Worlds, Ancient Texts:
the Power of Tradition and the
Shock of Discovery,
and the quote is the
following--it's a very important
quote,
I want you to follow it
closely: "Between 1550 and
1650 [it encompasses just the
time of Cervantes]
Western thinkers ceased to
believe that they could find all
important truths in ancient
books."
So whereas the early
Renaissance thought that
all-important truths could be
found in books,
now this has decreased.
Grafton goes on to quote Jesuit
José de Acosta--
a very common name in Spanish,
who wrote in his--this is a
book about the history of the
new world--
called Historia natural y
moral de las Indias.
This is Acosta quoted by
Grafton: "Having read that
what poets and philosophers
write of the Torrid Zone,
I persuaded myself that when I
came to the equator [he was
traveling to the New World]
I would not be able to endure
the violent heat,
but it turned out otherwise,
for when I passed the equator I
felt so cold that I was forced
to go into the sun to warm
myself.
What could I do then but laugh
at Aristotle's
meteorology?"
Unquote.
Ironically, then,
the proliferation of books
begins at the time when the
authority of the book was most
severely tested and ultimately
devalued.
The ability to read many books
did not bring one closer to the
truth but to an inordinate,
perhaps, infinite enlargement
of the library,
and to Don Quixote's madness,
or to Descartes "Je
pense, donc je suis,"
I think,
therefore I am,
I only know that I am because I
think,
and in this way he discards the
whole philosophical traditional
in books before it.
This, too, leads in the
direction of an increase in the
importance of the author.
Just as the classical tradition
is being refashioned or denied
altogether, so it's received
knowledge from the canonical
books being questioned.
The function of books changes
not only because the printing
press makes them available in
larger quantities,
but also because they are no
longer seen as reliable
purveyors of truth.
Experience becomes a very
important element in thinking in
philosophy and literature,
not books.
If Acosta in the 1590s can
laugh at Aristotle,
why not pick up then a
picaresque novel and have a good
laugh,
or a chivalric romance and be
entertained,
or aroused instead?,
or the Quixote, and have
a good time?
Reading book times is not
equated as before with the
acquisition of knowledge,
but increasingly with pleasure,
and the value of each book is
dependent an author whose
ability to produce such pleasure
is known.
The scrutiny of the library and
Altisidora's dream clearly show
some of the quandaries that this
new situation opens up.
Altisidora's dream is this
marvelous episode in Part II,
when a character--you will meet
her--
named Altisidora,
has a dream,
in which sees some devils
playing tennis,
and the balls are books,
and the rackets are flaming
rackets,
and when they hit the books,
the books,
poof!, explode,
and are pulverized.
It's a magnificent dream about
what I'm telling you about,
and you will get to it.
Of course, the book that is
pulverized most easily is
Avellaneda's apocryphal
Quixote,
as Cervantes takes advantage of
this episode to pocke fun at his
rival.
So this is why Ginés de
Pasamonte is so important.
Ginés de Pasamonte,
who now appears--and I don't
have the quote here but I'm sure
you remember--how he is
shackled.
He is covered with chains from
head to foot,
he cannot move his head down to
reach his hands,
nor have his hands reach his
mouth.
It is as if he were possessed
of some demonic power;
slipperiness.
Here Cervantes is anticipating
kind of a romantic notion of the
author as a demonic figure,
but the most interesting thing
is that Ginés de
Pasamonte is also a self
portrait of Cervantes,
because at one point
Ginés describes himself
as being very unfortunate,
and the line is obviously a
self allusive line on the part
of Cervantes.
Ginés de Pasamonte is a
figure of Cervantes in the book:
lower class,
and also this inventiveness
that has to be contained by all
of these chains that hold him
down.
In Part II he will reappear,
and I can anticipate having a
lot of fun with Ginés
when he appears in Part II,
and he is a master puppeteer,
he has a puppet theater and I
will not ruin the plot by
telling you what happens then,
but it's hilarious and it
dovetails what I have been
telling you about here.
Now, so this slipperiness in
the part of this author figure
is connected to all of these
games of authorship.
The slipperiness of Cide Hamete
Benengeli, the slipperiness of
the translator who has the text
translated, and all of that.
They are all contained within
this figure of Ginés de
Pasamonte, this pícaro.
But there is one more aspect of
Ginés that I want to
discuss,
and that is contained in an
essay that you have in the
Casebook about
Ginés being cross-eyed,
and I am going to simply
summarize it because we're
coming to the end of the hour
and I direct you to that essay
of mine if you want the details.
You remember that when
Ginés is introduced it is
said: "Behind all of this
came a man of some 30 years of
age of a goodly aspect except he
seemed to thrust one eye into
the other."
What he means is that
Ginés is cross-eyed--
"metía un ojo en
el otro,"
we still say in Spanish.
Now, vision,
of course, is tied to
representation.
You represent what you see,
and Ginés,
being an author-figure who is
cross-eyed, is very suggestive.
First of all,
because being cross-eyed gives
Ginés a shifty look.
When you say,
but you look at somebody in the
eye to see if they're being
sincere,
if there is something in the
eye, still doesn't have to be
cross-eyed,
then the person doesn't appear
sincere.
So being cross-eyed gives
Ginés a shifty appearance
going with his slipperiness.
Also, he's Janus-like,
that if you look at him from
one side,
you see one this way,
if you look at it from the
other side,
the eye is going the other way,
so he's two things at the same
time,
whether you look at him from
one side or the other,
so there is no center,
no stable figure of
Ginés de Pasamonte
because he is cross-eyed.
He has a monocular
cross-eyedness,
that is, one is the one that
goes into the other.
So therefore,
if you have two lines of site
that normally meet here,
in this object,
and that object is represented
to your mind well,
if you are cross-eyed they meet
here,
and therefore,
the object is distorted.
This is what monocular
cross-eyedness means.
Also, it leads to a double
vision, what is called
diplopia--Sorry for this.
So Ginés suffers from
this cross-eyedness,
diplopia,
meaning double vision;
he sees two things at the same
time.
And he is this figure of the
author,
the figure of the author who,
like the Cervantes of the first
prologue,
who has to divide himself in
two persons,
is two within his own vision,
because he sees double.
What I'm trying to say is this.
You will see that one of the
topics in the Quixote
criticism is perspectivism,
that reality is seen from
various perspectives.
The perspective of each one of
the characters,
and that supposedly reality,
in the end of some of these
hilarious discussions,
in the end, is the sum total of
all of these perspectives.
What I'm trying to say is that
there is no such thing,
that within each individual
there is already perspectivism
because there is more than one
view of things.
I want to emphasize this.
Ginés sees two things;
he's not just simply one
perspective.
There is perspectivism within
him, not just from all of the
others' perspectives.
This complicates the issue a
lot more,
particularly,
when you take into account that
he is presented as an author
figure,
as a storyteller in the
Quixote.
Storytellers in the
Quixote tend not to be very
healthy, either physically or
mentally, and Ginés is
important because of that.
So we're going to leave it at
that,
and in the next class we're
going to about another one of
these galley slaves in passing,
the one that I have called in
my book Love and the Law,
'the prisoner of sex,' and this
is the minor character,
this is a really minor,
minor character--
one paragraph.
If you go back to this episode
of the galley slave in XXII,
the guy who is carrying on with
four women at the same time,
two of whom were cousins of his.
So we're going to be talking
about that and other matters
that are in your syllabus,
but I'll begin by talking about
the prisoner of sex.